you know what movie that you did that
I'm really fascinated by the Joan Jett
movie The Runaways thing the way you
prepared for that role is to just hang
out with her all day yeah like like live
with her almost 24 hours she was she was
with me the entire shoot I never there
was there was um really never a day that
she wasn't there yeah if you had to do
that movie all over again
do you want the person you're doing in
essence you're doing the story of their
life do you really want them hanging out
with you commenting that doesn't feel
real that feels real that doesn't in
this case I would do it again the exact
same way because she's so intimidating
like staggeringly so like when you meet
her like like she has this armor on that
is just like it's kind of penetrating
she's tough she's really tough yeah but
then you realize that the reason she is
that way is because she is a delicate
little angel baby like she's she's very
like it's a self-protective thing
because she's super Soulful and like
sensitive and very she's such a yeah
exactly and so like we really got along
really well so her suit of armor is this
tough girl kinda thing but if you get to
know her and you get under the hood
she's very emotional and a delicate
person oh yeah no the reason that she
has the reason she is who she is is not
because she's like yeah tough It's
because she's like a poet playing Joan
Jett and hanging around with her all the
time to me would be tough just because I
wouldn't want to disappoint her it was
no at first it was awful like I can't
rehearse I can't commit to rehearsal I
can't show anyone anything before it
happens it just feels like ridiculous
until it's like until it's go time I
just find it to be an absurd act I get
it and so she was like we're rehearsing
Cherry Bomb and I was kind of like
barely half-assed like doing it and she
was like I could see the worry in her
face because she doesn't know my process
she hasn't made a bunch of movies you
know what I mean I was just like
I saw her face kind of fall and
genuinely question whether or not this
was going to go down and I was like oh
like I started crying and like I was
like I promise it's gonna be okay as
soon as we started shooting it was like
not only did she allow me to kind of
live in it and like she kind of handed
her stuff over to me in a way that I
didn't have to be exactly like her
because that would just be that would
suck that would suck it would be you
doing an impression exactly and that
wouldn't be really him I understand that
when you when you're pretending before
the camera's rolling you almost want to
give it about 30 of your energy yeah
because it feels stupid it's ridiculous
yeah yeah yeah and and then when you get
in front of the camera then you feel
like that's my job and I know what I'm
gonna do yeah well then you can really
commit to it and really be swept up in
something
foreign